first of all i have to ask you how's the
puppy
he's good he's not here at the moment
usually he's with me
so sweet you like this blanket
he's good he's just um he bites
everything
he's like it's like really like you
gotta watch them a lot
it's a full-on thing it's a full thing
[Music]
yep sean's from busy besides welcoming
tarzan to the family the 22 year old
premiered
his netflix documentary in wonder last
month and today
he has released his fourth studio album
wonder
[Music]
sounds like relationship material from
the get-go how did your own relationship
shape and influence the material this
time around on the album
camilla was with me during the whole
process so i really had someone
who was kind of by my side pushing me to
stick with my ideas because
the interesting thing about being an
artist i feel like is there's always
these moments of self-doubt
that kind of make you feel like you want
to just throw it all away
um that make you forget the excitement
you had when you first came up with the
original concept
and she was always there to push me
through those moments
and uh yeah i mean it really that is
like a superpower seriously i think
having someone
be by your side to be able to be like no
you're onto something don't don't don't
get discouraged keep going
um so yeah i owe that to her a lot so
the song
24 hours on the album is talking about
taking the plunge and moving in with
that special someone
full time
is this foreshadowing for a new house
yeah and we we've been looking for a
house for a while but i think with uh
covet and everything we've just been
spending time with family
yeah it'll happen one day there's no
rush but we're definitely searching
whether it's in miami or toronto i'm not
sure yet
i'd say toronto i'm just saying you'd
say
i just feel like you may be potentially
a little biased
maybe a little bit maybe a little bit
[Music]
with monster with justin bieber i know
he was your idol for so many years what
was it like
in being in the recording studio finally
with him
super normal at first and then i think i
might have had two to five minutes of
like
shock and pure disbelief and um i mean
he's just
so talented and so kind and so gracious
and so amazing to be around just been a
really amazing experience being able to
work with him and also more than that
being able to become friends and kind of
connect on a deeper level than just
a song you know so between the two of
you who's more critical of their own
work
would it be you doing it doing a line
over and over again or would it be just
in doing a line over and over again
i don't really know i i don't know to be
honest but i know i'm really critical
that's what i think that's what i can
say